[Music]
[Music]
sri lanka
2009 the president of sri lanka at the
time started pushing to build a new port
in a small town at the south end of sri
lanka
why because ambitious projects like this
that promise prosperity make you look
like a good caring politician
the only problem was that everyone
including their own government studies
estimated that the port wouldn't be
profitable
and when they went to their neighboring
indian companies for funding and
construction
even they said the same thing it was an
economic dud done
and it's an economic dud now but then
the president announced that the project
had been green lighted
with the help of none other than china
the chinese government's export-import
bank gave them a loan of 307 million
dollars
on the surface this looked very generous
we're helping a developing country build
infrastructure when other selfish
countries wouldn't help
but it came with some clever terms the
port would have to be built by the ccp's
preferred company
china harbor so that it looks like money
is going to this developing country but
then it just gets funneled back right
into the chinese economy
so there's really no risk of the chinese
government and only upside
and another requirement was that sri
lanka would be required to let the
chinese government know exactly who is
coming in and out of the port
so they also get valuable intel on top
of everything
the port opened in 2012 and the
forecasts were right no one was
interested in its new ports
where only 34 ships docking there in
2012 compared to nearly 4 000 ships at
sri lanka's other port colombo
and his finances were in the hole so the
president went back to china for another
loan
this time for 757 million dollars china
agreed
but with the condition that the first
loan of 307 million dollars would go
from a one to two percent interest rate
to a 6.3
interest rate a very steep hike then a
new sri lankan president was elected and
took over a country shackled in debt
debt had increased three times to 44.8
billion
and by the end of 2015 they had a 4.7
billion dollar payment due
money that they didn't have so what did
they do
they took out another loan from china
this time for one billion dollars to
help pay off that upcoming debt payment
the equivalent of you taking out a loan
to help pay off your monthly credit card
statements
or in other words it's safe to say that
sri lanka found itself at the mercy of
the chinese government
not at the point of a gun or at the
crack of a whip but through the
double-edged sword of debt
it was drowning in debt payments and was
left with an expensive port no one
wanted to use
their only option go to the negotiation
table and hope that chyna would show
some mercy and let them cancel some of
this debt
yeah that didn't happen and now china
owns 85
of that port and managed to squeeze 15
000 acres of land around that port as
well
which adds just one more strategic
infrastructure project in china's
growing portfolio around the globe
and where does china have their eyes set
on now africa
the fascinating math behind
macroeconomics drives some of the
biggest decisions that affect our lives
whether or not we should build this
expensive port that might put us in debt
to afford power
what countries should we invest in based
on projected gdp whether or not the
federal reserve should raise interest
rates or keep them low
and if you want to learn how it works
the best place to do so is brilliant.org
their statistics course makes these
concepts simple because the best way to
learn something is not do lectures
repetition doing odd number
exercises from a textbook no research
has shown that the best way to learn is
through problem solving
and brilliant is a website and app built
off of this very principle
that you learn best while doing and
solving in real time
get instant feedback and improve rapidly
with brilliant active and interactive
learning platform
jump right into solving problems and be
coached bit by bit until before you
realize
it you've learned a fundamental concept
in stem or other subjects
there aren't any tests or grades just
pick a course you're interested in and
get started
with help along the way and brilliant
has something for everyone
whether you want to learn the basics of
math statistics computer science
or dive into cutting edge topics like
cryptocurrency or quantum computing
if you want to join me in the community
of 8 million learners and educators
today
click the link in the description below
or visit brilliant.org
jake tran to sign up for free and get 20
off
dead traps death diplomacy is nothing
new in fact
china is probably just taking a page out
of the original master at this game
the us because the similarities are
shocking
in the 70s 80s and 90s the u.s and u.s
companies use these exact same
strategies on countries like panama
colombia ecuador and more
as john perkins laid out in his infamous
book confessions of an economic hitman
what is an economic hit man and what is
your story as an economic hit man
well so jake let me first say that my
official title was i was chief economist
at a major international consulting firm
and i had a staff and i my job was
really
to use my staff and to and to identify
countries with resources our
corporations
want like oil and minerals and such
things
and then arrange a huge loan to that
country from the world bank or one of
its sister organizations
but the money didn't go to the country
instead it went directly
to our own corporations u.s corporations
to build big infrastructure projects
in those countries things like power
plants and industrial parks and highways
and ports
that benefited first of all our
companies that made huge profits off
these things and second of all a few
wealthy families
in these countries families that you
know typically rule the countries with
an eye on thumb sometimes and
and they benefited because they own the
industry they own the commercial
establishments they owned the banks they
owned all of that and so
more electricity better electricity more
highways and ports
that helped them but the problem was
that that the loans
also uh worked they were the collateral
for the loan
was the resources that were still under
the ground usually like oil that hadn't
been exported
exploited and so the idea was that they
would take on these loans and over time
they would allow our corporations to
come in and take their resources
in the meantime they had to pay off
interest on the loans
and so the most of the people in the
country suffered terribly
money was diverted from education health
care and other social
services to pay off the interest so we'd
go back in usually under the guise of
the international monetary fund
policing organization and say okay so
you're not paying off your loan so
you sell your oil real cheap to our
corporations without environmental or
social regulations
let the united states build a military
base on your soil
privatize your your businesses your
public sector businesses your
education system your water and sewage
systems etc
and sell them to our investors cheap
vote with us at the next united nations
vote against cuba
or whatever so it was really it truly is
a form
it still goes on of colonialism but as
you pointed out
typically without the military although
the threat of military intervening is
always sort of
lurking in the background why did the
u.s go through all this effort to
enslave these less developed countries
or ldcs
simple when you're a global superpower
you need a lot of resources to stay on
top
oil energy raw materials places to put
military bases
nations under your influence so you can
call them up when you need something
like votes at the un
and so on so what happens when a country
you're going after can't pay his debts
you elaborated on it a little bit but
can you go into a little bit more detail
we're so happy
you know we're just so energy
because the imf goes in and restructures
the loan international monetary fund for
those that don't know it creates
what are called saps structural
adjustment policies
and conditionalities watch this video to
learn more about the us's debt traps
today china is in a similar position
they are desperate for energy
money and resources to continue their
astronomical climb to the top
china has surpassed the us on oil
imports and china gets a third of its
oil from africa
along with 20 of china's cotton africa
has half of the world's manganese for
steel production along with a ton of
other metals needed for electronics
as china's middle class grows their cost
of labor goes up
which means that ironically now they
have to turn elsewhere for cheaper labor
of course having more countries out with
you and not the us is always a good
thing
and as africa's 1.2 billion people
urbanize
at breakneck speeds countries willing to
risk billions to build infrastructure
there
could be facing a once in a lifetime
opportunity to make billions maybe even
trillions over the long run
and it looks like china is the only one
willing to take that risk
what's happening now is is china's
coming in and offering better deals
i think the chinese learn from the
mistakes that that russia's economic hit
men in the united states
economic hit and made i don't think
they're making those mistakes
they're going to make their own set of
mistakes but they're not making those
and so actually president xi has has
gone on record
uh if it's promising and i've got in
front of me right now that
the the the four points that he's he's
recently made as a promise to any
country
where they go in and you're quite
correct that they go in and they bring
in their own work
forces they bring their own engineering
companies and they use resources as
collateral just as we did but he's also
promised that one
we won't interfere in other countries
internal affairs
two we won't impose our will on other
countries in any way
three we won't attach political agendas
to assistance programs
and four we won't seek selfish political
gains
through our investment and financial
policies so
china basically saw everything that the
us did
and russia did that these countries
didn't like like they addressed all
their pain points and basically just
flipped it around
and got rid of all those pain points at
a cheaper price
yeah which brings us to step one
step number one offer to build
infrastructure
you the chinese government have your say
on corporations and banks go to these
less developed countries or ldcs
and offer them loans or debt to build
infrastructure if there's no existing
infrastructure
you start with mines power plants water
plants the basics
they will inevitably say yes to all this
debt because debt is like rocket fuel
if the debt is used properly to increase
productivity
more jobs more products etc then there's
a net positive and you can scale to the
moon
the politicians getting offered this
rocket fuel only see this good side
but as these infrastructure projects get
bigger more complex more expensive and
require more forecasting from experts
that same rocket field that can take you
to the moon can also make your nation
crash and burn under all this debt
the same goes for any other kind of debt
like vc funding for startups
along with that these african countries
are like sri lanka these are risky
expensive infrastructure projects that
may or may not be profitable
so no one else is going to fund it these
projects also look great for the local
politicians because they'll look like
the savers of these nations
bringing in jobs urbanization and so on
if you look at it from a governmental
side or from the side of politics i
would say that
most politicians especially in africa
they really like it
and lastly this also looks great for the
citizens because of the same promises of
prosperity
so in a nutshell it's an easy sell and
the countries practically always say yes
but again you only give them the loan
under the condition that it's chinese
companies that build out these projects
at inflated prices
therefore the money goes from the
state-owned banks to the ldc
and then right back into the pockets of
the state-owned enterprises
most aid that the chinese government
gives there is this ratio of
70-30 approval 70 of the project has to
be handled by chinese companies
and 30 by local fans it's a thin veil
but but
actually what actually happens is the us
government through usaid or one of its
agencies
gives the loan to the country
and the country hires us yeah that's
what i found really clever
was you're giving foreign aid which
looks and sounds really
generous and helpful and altruistic but
then the money goes straight back
into u.s companies and u.s contractors
so the country you're trying to help
just ends up with debt
and an infrastructure project that may
or may not be profitable
am i getting that correctly yes and the
infrastructure project probably is
profitable for the wealthy families
if the project ends up being profitable
everyone wins
if it underperforms like sri lanka you
have more leverage over these nations
almost or it's a financial system that
china gives to africa
it's been back or has to be backed by
natural resources
most countries have been in situations
where because they couldn't pay
it authorizes automatically the chinese
government to step into the country
and then take all these natural
resources which they use
as collateral either way this country
will be under your influence
step number two expand once these basic
infrastructure projects like mines and
power plants are up
they're gonna need other infrastructure
like roads ports trains power lines
telecom to support
these mines and power plants so rinse
and repeat the process for those
projects
getting the countries more and more in
debt step number three cheap labor
now that you have the basic building
blocks of an urbanized economy
you can use africa as china's new china
for cheap labor
think basic low-value ad manufacturing
for shoes textiles and other basic
products that require
a lot of labor step number four more
expansion
that cheap labor will have to live shop
and eat somewhere so they'll turn to you
for even more infrastructure
this time in the form of residential and
commercial buildings
step number five sit back relax because
now you basically have complete control
if all goes according to plan you china
will have your fingers
in all aspects of africa's economy the
fastest growing region in the world
from every segment of the infrastructure
to the continent's debt
when you look at africa today this is
pretty much exactly what has gone down
in 2009 china surpassed the us as
africa's largest trading partner
at around 200 billion dollars per year
africa
exports around 15 percent of their goods
to china think raw materials like fuel
lubricant iron ore metals
and africa imports 14 to 21 of goods
from china
think more advanced stuff like machinery
transportation telecom equipment and so
on
so they have a very productive
relationship china has invested a
staggering 300 billion dollars in africa
that 300 billion dollars has funded 40
of all infrastructure projects that have
been happening over there
with the help of over 10 000 chinese
companies operating in africa
valued at over 2 trillion or in other
words china practically has a monopoly
on all the construction going on over
there
any construction project you see in
africa that is higher than three stories
or longer than three kilometers in terms
of roads
is probably being done by chinese
companies the reason is simple
one it's written into the loan and two
african contractors don't have the
capacity for huge construction projects
and chinese firms undercut western firms
on price there's the 3.2 billion
290 mile long railway in kenya the
largest infrastructure project in the
country
there's the 3.5 billion dollar 470 mile
electric railway in ethiopia
that became engulfed in corruption
there's another light rail system in
ethiopia funded built and operated by
china
and suspiciously one of the countries
that was highly vulnerable to death
distress
djibouti which had deaths swelling from
50 to 85 percent in just two years
gets the honor of hosting china's first
overseas military base
but i'm sure it was just a coincidence
there are a ton of other projects as
well
and the results cracks have started to
show the ethiopia light rail ended up
consuming a quarter of ethiopia's 2016
budget
nigeria had to renegotiate its deal with
chinese contractors because it couldn't
pay up
kenya's railway went four times over the
original budget or six percent of its
gdp
and in 2012 alone the imf found that
china owned 15
of africa's external debt and by 2015
two-thirds or 66
of all new loans were coming from china
so right now the debt is still
manageable
but it all depends on how profitable
these infrastructure projects end up
being
and how much more debt how much more
rocket fuel these countries take on in
the future
do you think they're using the same
tactics of you know
questionable studies building the
statistics
that you talked about in your book well
let me give a couple of examples of the
terrible mistakes that china's made so
and and i'll go back to ecuador uh a
country that i know well but
it's it's a in a book i'm running now i
call ecuador the
canary in china's cage because i think
it serves as a warning
they built a huge hydroelectric plant
there that was supposed to serve
more than 30 percent of the country's
capacity the biggest hydroelectric plant
ever built
and they built it on a fault line next
to an active volcano
in a very sensitive ecosystem in the
rain forest
as for politics there's actual evidence
that chinese debt has had an effect
a study by aid data found that if an
african country recognizes taiwan
as a country they get on average 2.7
fewer infrastructure projects per year
if an african nation happens to cast the
same votes as china in the united
nations
they'll get on average 1.8 more
infrastructure projects per year
and this is just one stat that shows the
influence of chinese debt that we're
able to quantify
on the other side of the story when you
look at these african countries
the majority of them actually happily
welcome chinese investment which is
understandable
and china's done more in africa than
anywhere
i don't care you could say uk america
germany british you can i don't care who
you call
no one's done more work in china to
benefit africans
than the chinese they've been very
clear that they're about trade and
that they're not about influencing our
country's policies
we were very clear that we wanted to
influence countries policies
africa saw china's astronomical growth
from very similar humble beginnings in
the 1900s
and they hope that they can replicate
china's success china
we developed that's the other thing that
they can show
over 30 years they had economic growth
of more than 10 percent
it's never happened before in history at
least in any history that any of us can
find and you know they get rid of 800
they
they brought 800 million people out of
poverty which is more than the whole
rest of the world combined
the infrastructure has had a net
positive on african countries in terms
of living standards
jobs and so forth and chinese
infrastructure is also cheaper than
western construction with on the surface
less strings attached with chinese
assistance it's alone it gives a
long-term payback
which most africans enjoy and also
the west do not give a long-term payback
so
most most africans are kind of like
logged in with that and they prefer that
politicians don't have to worry about
the u.s shoving democracy down their
throats
would much rather take loans and aid
from china than the united states
because they don't make these demands on
us and they've never
assassinated one of our leaders but as
the former governor of nigeria's central
bank said
we must see china for what it is a
competitor
africa must recognize that china like
the us russia britain brazil and the
rest
is in africa not for african interests
but its own
i think the relationship between africa
and the chinese government is probably a
lot like the relationship between the
chinese government and chinese
entrepreneurs
as long as you're moving in the same
direction as their agenda all is well
but as soon as you step out of line the
sickle comes down
the challenge is when they start to see
that that
entrepreneur is a threat to the
leadership
of the chinese communist party then they
can be taken down a notch and so
in the meantime those entrepreneurs are
richly rewarded
by having preferential treatment from
the government in terms of rules
and regulations but also access to
capital and
the motivation is i can get really
really wealthy
and maybe i can get really really
wealthy i can establish a nest egg
outside the country and maybe i can
actually leave the country
as many have so they've they've moved
their assets out
they've gotten rich and then they've
they've escaped china
so what do you think of china's
involvement in the region the same
country where we education camps
disappearing billionaires like jack ma
hong kong taiwan and a whole host of
other problems has perfect win-win
relationships with these countries with
no ulterior motives
that is up for you to decide but i
personally wouldn't put my money on it
you know they make a matrix and they
make the comparison
china comes out looking pretty good to
them and who knows in the long run what
will happen
americans believe that china has the
same objectives as the u.s
and russia did during the cold war that
there's this animosity to dominate the
world
in her opinion china doesn't have that
that goal it does want to dominate
trade and commerce but it's not trying
to dominate militarily
however having said that of course we
have to look at what's going on in hong
kong
myanmar and taiwan and the south china
sea
and tibet so china certainly has has the
ability to be very aggressive
when it wants to china probably is going
to kind of
follow the old model but on the other
hand
we've also seen throughout history there
have been times when things have
radically changed
china certainly is making mistakes and
and yet it continues to sell these
projects in the same way
it's been a little over a year since the
original video i made on enslaving third
world countries through debt came out so
i thought
that this would be a very appropriate
time to make this follow-up video
don't forget that this video is
sponsored by brilliance whenever there's
a new breakthrough or innovation in the
stem fields like quantum computing for
example
i usually just go i'm brilliant to get
an understanding of how everything works
behind the scenes because i know that
i'm gonna get a very simple explanation
all in one place so invest in yourself
and support the brands that help make
this channel possible by going to
brilliant.org
jake tran to sign up for free and for 20
off link below
you can check out the full interview i
did with john perkins the author of
confessions of an economic hitman with
the link below
one of my favorite interviews i've done
so far john is a super genuine guy with
like a whole wealth of knowledge
if you like this video you're definitely
going to enjoy the full interview too
and that will be linked below you can
also connect with john
johnperkus.org and check out his book
with the links below if you are new here
subscribe because it's free and we make
video essays like this on the most
provocative
stuff in the world of business every
single week for free red button below
that is going to wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i'll see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you